huh
all right can you guys hear me
or am I talking to myself
am I talking to myself
I'm sorry guys I have no clue what
happened there
I'm so frustrated right now
everything was so good
my my graphics card updated and I guess
it crashed obs
get King back in here I sent him an
invite
you can or cannot hear me
when you said no the rest said yes
okay we can hear you all right I
appreciate it
all right can you hear me King
King
you hear me can you hear me yeah all
right you hear me we're back apologize
for that guys uh I don't I don't know
what happened with that
I'm not I'm not gonna show anything else
on the middle screen all right so what
is showing right now on my screen
it's showing um that we're not live
on my end it says this is upcoming
yeah people in the chat saying we're
good
okay let me close that let me go to iron
Lord's Channel itself let me do it again
it's no problem long as they saying it's
fine I don't care
all right there we go
there we go yeah they're saying that
we're live now I had to click out leave
and come right back
okay see that that's where I got it
confused from uh bookable uh uh yeah is
is where everything went down at that's
that's and that's what I was saying I
was like
he left at the end of season two Luke
came and got him and then you had the
book of boba and excuse me
the book of boba uh got him back with
the Mandalorian and now that we have
season three that's when they're gonna
kick off and I mean it's it's
it's good you know I love the um
the funny Dynamic where you know Pedro
Pascal is a daddy to everybody in the
universe from Ellie to groco
you can't escape it
yeah it's he I I personally enjoy him
more
and this than I do in Last of Us
uh I think he well because his face is
covered
no I just I I maybe it's because I have
more of a personal connection with Joel
and I personally feel like some of the
things he's done in the show Joe
wouldn't do if that makes sense yeah
yeah I get it it makes a hell of a lot
of sense
oh my God you're ridiculous it makes it
makes so much sense that you're bias in
your video game knowledge listen I hated
him in the Mandalorian I'm gonna keep it
100 with you
um I hated him in the Mandalorian is
because of him they had to change the
script around and because he want to
take his face out and he want to be seen
and he was making such a big problem I
was like yo uh get him out of there and
recast them but they stuck with him uh
and I guess they're going to go back to
a form of fashion in this season and
this season he's going to keep his
helmet on he's going to go get
re-initiated and he's gonna lock his
face away so I don't want to hear no
more of Joel or Pedro Pascal or whoever
he want to be sticking his face out
don't mess up my characters you know how
I feel about Hugh Jackman
same thing but um
what what what's your rating that you
give this episode
uh I give it a a three you give it a
three I give it a four
off of the
off of everything that they show the
potential of uh future episodes and the
fact that Pedro didn't take his face out
look I I put I put the Emos together it
looks like a bunch of popcorn sitting
around each other
I feel you I think that uh you know this
is a good first episode obviously we're
not gonna see like a lot of a plot in
the first four no definitely not but I
do think this did a good job
establishing expectation and boundaries
on what this season uh for the most part
is going to be by so let's let's let's
go on to man
King we're going to talk about Creed
Three
um you know you gave me a little bit of
bars before IOP I'm a I'm a I'ma eat my
Jolly Ranchers and listen to you talk
about Creed 3 because I didn't watch it
to be honest with you
if I would have went and watched it it
was only because of this thing I don't
normally watch Boxing shows but go I'm
listening I'm a huge Rocky fan Rocky one
holds a a huge place in my heart
I believe the Rocky movies are
masterpieces in cinema art
right
um I I believe that this this is It's a
staple in Americana it's it's it's it's
a part of the fabric of of conversation
it's so steeped in Americana that
Sylvester Stallone
is not a real boxer yet he has a statue
in Philadelphia for a fictional
character from a movie
that's how steep is in is is in in
Americana
Philadelphia is the home of the Philly
Fighters
born and raised Joe Frazier left hook
you you got Bernard Hopkins
it's crazy
how
Philadelphia is known for boxing and
it's known for Rocky those steps people
run up those steps they put their hands
in the air like Rocky
you ever had all the ingredients for
something
but you had the wrong chef
and the food don't come out right
this food didn't come out right
there's no way that you have Michael B
Jordan
that I thought Creed one was successful
I thought Creed 2 was successful so
Michael B Jordan can act in Creed one
and he can act in Creed too
there's a no-brainer for creed 3.
you have Jonathan Majors with just his
eyes and his face
he can act his way around tons of people
circles around them
he didn't do anything in uh Loki
and his King
was phenomenal
just from the acting part just from the
thought of what he's going to do to you
later
was great Lovecraft country
beautiful he's a great actor
all the pieces were there
Michael Kugler
and John uh Michael B Jordan
didn't direct this film didn't land the
ship
didn't do what they were supposed to do
the movie feels like a tick tock movie
oh God
it feels
rushed everything is rushed from the
moment they're in the ring it's rushed
from the moment his boy gets home is
rushed from the uh from the the first
fight scene it's rushed the fight the
fighters feel like amateurs their style
is amateuristic
you go to get Watch Rocky films to get
inspired you go to to get uh the feeling
of combat
there was no heart in this movie
there was no soul in this movie there
was no Sylvester Stallone and Sylvester
Stallone is the one who does the scripts
you you take the person who made it
this was my fear with the last of us is
Neil druckman around
and those episodes that you know Neil
didn't have his fingers in kind of fall
flat
well Sylvester didn't have his fingers
in any of this script
and it falls flat this is absolutely the
worst
Rocky movie
Creed movie
put out
the worst I will take I will take the
one with Tommy Morrison over this one
any day
yo Tommy
my ring is outside y'all know that
he goes out and he fights Tommy Gun
outside
I'm getting Goosebumps just thinking
about it
his son the Dynamics the heart the soul
he's watching his his son is watching
him train Tommy Gun and he's not
training his son
it's it's these little things that Rocky
movies bring if you go watch Creed one
you will understand exactly what I'm
talking about Creed Three is absolute
trash I don't care what marketing says I
don't care what any and it's not an
indictment
on the actors
everybody there like like addict says
it ain't his fault he don't care
I want results it's it's the same way
that you know people feel about games
the the result and how you play the game
in the in the end results is all people
care about No One's Gonna care about the
difficulties that happen during
development sure you could take that
into consideration at the end of the day
that doesn't stop the final result from
coming out and the result was trash
I sat there and I watched the movie you
know my son was like oh it's cool and my
wife was like it's cool then we sat down
and and this is what I do I start
breaking down the movies I start playing
the movies back in my head some movies I
gotta go watch a couple of times but I I
would never have to watch this movie a
couple of times to come up to the same
thing
every Rocky film you go round by round
they did two rounds
and then came back and said all right
round 11.
what the
what
none of the moves that he was able to do
uh that's Dame that's Jonathan Major's
character
Diamond Dame
none of the moves that he was able to do
before
he used here
he gets a title shot off of his first
professional fight
what the hell is this and what made up
fantasy world is this crap
admissible
it was that's trash that's one of the
absolute garbage
that's one of the reasons I started
watching uh UFC is because of Dana White
oh it seems like Dana White had control
of this because you would have hated
this I'm so happy that you didn't get a
chance to see it I'm so happy that you
guys
I'm so happy because when you said well
you know I got to drive this way to the
AMC that's over there and he was like
well you know King can you do it or
whatever and I was like good after
because I saw it already and I was like
oh hell no addict
hmm
listen
if you can get other means to go watch
it go watch it
was scream about to come out yeah scream
comes out this week I believe
I do ought to watch that like because I
gotta I gotta do scream and next week I
got to do
um no this week I gotta do operation
Fortune the guy Richie film
I was gonna do it on Monday but we would
have had too much stuff on the show so
I'm gonna do that this week I'm gonna do
it probably I'm doing it on definitely
on Friday uh next week's Shazam
23rd
next week is uh well I guess we'll do a
scream spoiler cast I don't let me ask
you this uh I'll actually you know we'll
talk about that after the show yeah yeah
I I feel you on this you know I felt the
disgust but you know what's funny I see
people on on Twitter saying it was a
list show movies you know why you know
okay
yeah people on Twitter yo Yobe
you just saved me a few bucks I'll catch
it when it comes out to physical that's
on God you said uh and scream is on what
what what what day does screen come on
anybody know hit me in the chat what did
the screen come out on the 10th okay so
then I got to see it next week so we'll
be talking about scream and we'll be
talking about
um operation Fortune uh and then you
know Mario 6 Mario comes out soon
we have a lot of movies coming up
my rating popcorn rating for this and we
don't give zeros here because you know
everybody puts an effort it's a one
popcorn it's a one popcorn is it is
there at least butter on the popcorn
there's no butter on the popcorn and
some of the kernels are burnt so we got
a burnt one popcorn
absolutely I was so man I was looking
forward to this ever born hit me up and
was like yo um I'm gonna go see Creed on
Friday did you see yeah cause he's gonna
you know rent the movie theater out and
go watch it at the movie theater
I told him bro hold that for John Wick
you know because we are going to be in
the same facility for John Wick
um we should do like an in-person
pre-recording oh yeah yeah a live one
but what we'll do for you guys is
because it would be the Lord's I I will
convince Coggin saw because we'll be all
together for PAX East and uh me Cox
solve we'll we'll do a pre-recording of
our thoughts on John Wick and that would
be the spoiler cast for uh for that week
yeah I'm gonna record it I'll have the
camera set up and stuff like that and
I'm gonna see if we can get a chance to
do it in the movie I'll bring my tripod
and uh bring the light and stuff and you
know we'll try to do that because we'll
only be in in packs so we we already
said that you know we'll catch dinner in
a movie and that'll be the movie that
we'll catch uh John John Wick but
I've never been more heartbroken
was seeing all the perfect ingredients
to win
and for them not to land the plane it
just
it just
it didn't mix and
I dare anybody
if you challenge me on this I dare
anybody go watch Creed one and put it up
against Creed 3. 101
anybody
anybody and you're gonna walk away
saying now that dude's right that dude's
absolutely right something you know it
comes down to it you know King
definitely gives it a one popcorn about
butter and some burnt burnt kernels yeah
burnt kernels uh next week we'll be
talking about scream uh so man I gotta
make sure I go see screen this weekend
now
I even think about that like time's just
flying so fast yep it's a 40 minute
drive I gotta make well be 40 minutes
into movies it's only seven minutes for
myself
that's pretty much the show guys I you
know I apologize for splitting this up
into two
oh that's annoying uh but there's not a
whole lot I can do about that
at least we're here to finish it yeah uh
you know what's funny is we came back
just so you can rant about Creed
I mean it is what it is but if anybody
can save a buck if I listen I'm gonna
give you my honest opinion on things
and if I feel something isn't worth your
money because we was going to talk about
the Chris Rock special I can get we're
going to give them a bonus about the
Chris Rock real quick before it becomes
irrelevant by next week we could talk
about that all right so watch the Chris
Rock special and it and it's called um
selective outrage
it's on Netflix it's on actually the
very first live show that Netflix has
ever done was that Chris Rock special it
it's
I liked it I'm gonna tell you
if it if if that thing is an hour long
50 minutes of it is whatever
50 minutes of it is him dancing around
the true subject what everybody wants
everybody's there for it and you know
what I gotta respect Chris Rock because
he knew yep what happened to him he
could cash out Netflix probably paid
that man so much money because everyone
knew what was up like yeah and you know
what's funny obviously he brings up the
slap you know that and you could tell is
it me King when I was listening to this
to to this comedy it really didn't seem
like he wanted to talk about it no he
didn't he it seemed like okay I have to
talk about it because that's why
everyone wants and I gotta make sure
it's funny and I gotta bring the bars
but he didn't go in in on will that I
thought he was going to he did the cool
little funny little jokes took a couple
Jabs of Jada and and pretty much got out
of there like well
like you can tell he respects well even
though he did that problem you could
tell he respects will and he hates he
hated that it happened he
he
said that will
was somebody that he loved
that it was somebody that he rooted for
and somebody that he always wanted to
win
he said out of everybody when the stuff
happened to him he called him he said he
didn't pick up my phone call but I
called him
and for everybody to be dissing you and
you pick on the guy
that you know you could beat I think
that probably hurts the most because it
was that telling part right there no man
ever wants to say that he knows that
somebody can beat him I don't give a
hell who you are weak strong whatever
nobody wants to say oh yeah that guy can
beat me but the fact of the matter is he
is probably two times his size
and I mean and he he kept it he kept it
funky he kept it a buck I gotta give
Chris Rock This I didn't find the comedy
special funny
but that was the last 10 15 minutes
he was on fire and he was on fire
because he was talking from his heart
and he was talking from his soul
and and and and I have to respect that
he didn't want a little bit during the
beginning
he was nervous getting to the end yeah
like and build up was crazy yeah and I
think
here's the question to you because he
messed up the joke
yeah the Jada joke yeah he messed up the
joke and he had to fix the joke the
concussion joke for the for the movie he
had to fix it and then he went right
back into it yeah and I
I want to know how you feel like will
need to respond to this
I think Wilson shut up same thing I said
about OJ
go shut up and sit down
to me
will one on that stage and SM and smack
that dude
he had this roast coming
there was nothing he could have done on
that I think if will just bunkers up
ignores the situation maybe even may
maybe even take it as a joke
and say you know funny I think he should
just completely keep quiet but if he
makes if he makes any statement it
better be going along with it it better
not be going against it he just would
have just shut up just just don't say
nothing at all
the the most poetic thing that Chris
Rock said was they kept asking him
how come you didn't do anything
he was like I was raised
I was raised by my parents
not to fight in front of white folks
I'll tell you
I'm going to tell you old school
old school black parents
old school black grandparents
I tell you because I remember with my
with my black grandma
that's my father's side
the other one the rest of our souls
Puerto Rican
we in Macy's and we downtown
and me and my little cousin is you know
tough something up in there
don't you fight in front of these white
folks you still and I'm laughing in my
head when he said it
because this is what's been told to us
and for him to say it in the crowd it's
for him to say it on a live
he beat Will Smith at his own game
in his face
I was raised right my mom is in the
crowd I'm going to be better than you
and that Cuts Like a Knife and plus
when it happened
I was like okay if it would have been
another person that doesn't have a
comedy background a comedian background
I would have been like
you're bugging but I understand but the
fact that a comedian went up there a
former comedian that hasn't really
practiced but he knows the practices and
slapped him
made it 10 times worse and the fact that
no one reprimanded that dude no one
escorted well off that stage no one
escorted him out of that building they
literally low-key let Chris Rock
continue being a host to something after
he was just assaulted
oh hold on one second hmm
Dragonheart Yogi
I love this man what'd he do
you're very very very cool dude
not only you know when Halo was coming
out you know the Paramount thing
he just sent me Samuel Jackson
on fortnite fortnite skin
yo
we gonna hook up brother
I owe you something we gonna get some
some sushi or something we go hang out
bro
I owe you that yo I thank you thank you
so much I've been meaning to jump back
on fortnite but when it comes to that
we'll just just take it take it like a
champ don't talk about it because it's
like you know if you take this and you
don't say nothing and you move on with
your life and you just pretty much have
that mentality I had that coming
I was in the wrong it is what it is and
you move on I guarantee you
that works better than you responding
because if you respond it's just gonna
look more like you it's gonna it's gonna
get worse for him but the funniest thing
the best part that Chris Rock did when
he said that you know I was raised by my
parents
that's an that's an indictment on Will's
because you don't have any home training
and you're acting here you're outside
acting a fool
and there's no coming back from that
this is you're nothing that you're going
to say there's no excuse there's no
reason why I was in the moment there's
nothing and he did it with class and
dignity like he's took the smack with
class in the dignity you said y'all took
the smack like Pacquiao
yo the last 15 minutes of that special
was Chris Rock in rare form if anything
any trepidations up until then it was it
was mid
but that last 15 minutes
he was like
the easy you know I'm gonna say B I'm
not gonna say the words yeah he's like
he was like everybody called him a b the
football players the rapper plays and he
smacks me
the drink Champs called you will be
everybody yeah what I liked the most he
said is that woman hurt him way more
than he hurt me like because he doesn't
need to say that you know what I'm
saying because that kind of was like
look
you we still beefing
but I get what you going through
y'all at home yeah
it's crazy it's it's it's a real
eye-opening uh
piece of Comedy for you to go check out
if you didn't see it go see it
um
and and and and have a good time seeing
it just leave me your responses which I
think about it listen a lot of you guys
join the patreon we've seen an uptake in
the patreon and people uh actually you
know joining the patreon and having
conversation with us you can ask us
questions uh it's a whole bunch of
things back there for you to do for
y'all to do y'all can check the
reactions that we do we we recorded some
today those stuff is going to go up
attic is really anticipating the
reaction that I'm gonna do for the last
one I think we went on a little bit long
today so uh we'll probably just do the
next reaction probably another day but
he did chainsaw man I'm doing uh Attack
on Titan I did the whole first season
well I got one more episode then I
finished the first season then I'm gonna
jump into the second season and I'm so
on and so on and so on until I can catch
up to attic but uh you know I gotta
watch it because my wife wants to watch
Attack on title she's addicted to this I
don't even know why
if if we end right now can we just
finish that last episode let's go let's
do it let's let's do it right now we're
going in the podcast guys uh I got to
get this last episode yeah he wants to
schedule these out uh but I appreciate
it for coming through
and uh we will see